Hello everybody my name is Markiplier and welcome to the last episode of the Hundred Mario challenge because I'm about to fail.
If you're wondering why the level changed from the last one, it's because screw that level!
I only have four lives left.
I have four lives and I'm not happy, I am not happy.
I am an unhappy camper
I am sooo uuuuunnnhappy
You would not believe how unhappy I am about life and everything in life
and the life that I love to live and the living the love of the life that I have
and all the life love and the love of life that is coursing through my love veins for life and all of its wonderful liveness.
GOD! FUUUCK YOOOU!!!
CHARGIN'. THROUGH. THE. OPENING. TO. MURDER. MEEEE!
WEEEELL
EAT A DIIIICK BECAUSE YOU CAN!
I HOPE THAT ALL OF YOU
[Drelrblrl]
Well, hello!
Hello secret, I'll take some of you.
ANY MORE?
Anyone else wanna be a part of this?
A part of this pity party
Hosted by Markiplier
But now I got triple spray.
That'll make it a little easier.
Wish I'd gotten that from the beginning
Because
Frankly, I need all the help that I can get.
oh.
NOOooo!
WHY DID I LOSE IT?!
OOOHH! FUUUCK OOFFFff
OOOOH! FUCK YOU WHOLE!
Oh fuck that
Fuck everything about that...
Oh, goddammit
Aargh.
No!
Why?
GoooHAAA HA HA HA HAAA ha HAAA
He's like a fuckin' homing beacon!
IT'S SO BULLSHIT!
I was haaaAAAAVING IT!
I had it in the PALM
OF
MUH HAAND.
Don't fuckin' lose it, please.
NOOOOO
GOD
DAMMIT!
No!
Gah,
fuuhuhuck.
GO AWAAAHAAHAY
Thank you.
Thank You!
ThAnK yOu!
THANK YOU!
YES
YAAAAAASS
Oh
Gohaha
Ha
HA
Ooooh, but I didn't get any bonus lives, but goddammit
WhhhYYY COULDN'T HAVE BEEN LIKE THAAT?
aaaeAAAAAHH
I'm in such pain!
Okay... two lives left!
Can I make it with just two lives?
Five levels in two lives?!?!?
You bet I can!
*deep sigh*
I am broken inside. In every way, I am broken.
Please tell me that these assholes...
OH.
I didn't
I didn't even notice what they WEEERE!
ooouuh-kay I'm going for it.
Fuck you!
WHHHHYYYY
That was it. That was it. That was it.
That. was it.
Thaa-
That's it.
Just that's it.
Huuh.
Hauh.
Haah.
Oh My God.
If- ITS SO DISAPPOINTING! WHAT, IS THAT JUST THE END?! AM I SUPPOSE TO ROLL OVER AND GIVE UP...
...BEACAUSE THAT BULLSHIT GOT A PART OF ME?!
FUUUCK THAT!!
FUCK THAT!!
AH! IT'S SUCH BULLSHIT! I'm still mad from the last episode!
GODDAMMIT I'M SO SWEATY AND MY HAIR ISN'T DRY!!
AAAAAARRGH!!
[Intricately painful yelling]
[Immense sigh]
FUUCK EVERYTHING!
Hello everybody! Welcome back to the "Hundred Mario Challenge"! We haven't even started yet!
Because we haven't. Everybody be, quiet it's okay.
Nothin' going wrong, we're just gonna-
[deep sigh]
We're gonna do it ag- again!.. I mean for the first time! We're gonna do it again for the first time!
It's gonna be great.
Everyone's a happy camper especially me!
Fack you!
What is that?
What ar- What is all of these? Am I supposed to take this?
Do I need this?
For s-
What ar- Goddammit!
I don't know what you want from me...
...why am I on the first level doing the stupid key finding bullshit? GOD!
rea- Really?
Really?
REally?
REAlly?
REALly?
REALLy?
REALLY?
REALLY!
REALLY You're gonna throw that bullshit at me?
MUUUUUUUH
OHHHkay! Everything's fine.
Everything is 100% okay.
Know why? (WHY?)
Cause I love life.
And life is love.
Love is life.
Life is Love.
Life is all these things.
LIfe is luuuuving.
Life is lurhve.
Life is luhve.
Didn't I find another one before I got up here? Yeah, okay.
hOkay
So we're back into "normal" fashion- there's twooo-
Yeah there's two of these buggers.
There's another one.
This is going swimmingly.
I'm actually doing quite well, thank you.
For asking. I know you didn't really ask but it's...
it's OK because I'm gonna assume that you did.
Cos I love you.
I'm talking to myself.
Ground Pound! It's the technique that people wanted me to know about!
And I got all the keys, so that's good...
I can open that-
Well fuck this then,
I guess I'll never get out of here.
Fuck that.
Fuck you.
I mean thank you for letting me go through there!
Please lead me to the end,
because I don't wanna deal with this anymore.
Faaaack off, y'know fuck you.
Faaaaaaack yooooou.
Eat ten fireballs and then
drown in the river of magma.
Ugh.
Why do I have to do this...
Again?
Why must I torment myself...
Again?!
Why must I subject myself...
Again?!?
Ughhh...
First clear. I was the first clear of that level
and yet somehow,
It was ranked as 'Expert'.
Great!
Dat means dat I'm an asshole.
I don't know what I'm doing. *sigh*
Let's go for broke.
I like POWs.
Let's see how this does me.
Eeaaaaaaaaaand...
We're doing what, exactly?
I needed the spring.
Maybe I can jump on-
God dammit.
Gaawd dammit.
Are yooou kidding meeee?
Aoww fuck off!
This is just gonna be choices, and one of them kills me!
One of them is what I need.
That's- That's the way this whole map is gonna go, isn't it?
The way this whole douchy-
I can already tell it's douchy!
Because of what you're already putting in front of me.
I ca- I know douche when I see douche
*emotionless laugh*
Oh boy.
Wow. Yeah.
Am I gonna have to do it again?
Oh good!
I bet the POW this time because
the POW didn't work last time, so...
what else will I do with my-
Well that one led to death.
That's g-
I was right, but I was just too early because who would hAVE KNOWN THat a Thwomp would have been coming down
the chute, ready to slam into my nubile body?
No, d- NO na-
*Singing* "Everything is Awesome!"
"Everything is cool when you're part of the team!"
"Everything is awesooo*voice break*ooome!"
*tired singing* "Livin' our dream..."
Don't, please, just...
let me live.
Let me live my life.
Let me live my life with all the mistakes that I've made,
but just let me live.
That's all that I ask.
*laughs at his own patheticness*
That's all I ask!
*laughs a bit more*
Alright.
habagh
Fuck you.
Just ea- eat dicks.
Weeooow- Ah god, here we go again.
Well, Yoshi would be toooo simple.
I bet...
It's...
It's the spring!- it's the flower.
Alright!
Let's see what happens.
Probably not what I needed.
Well that doesn't seem promising.
Oh it was the spring.
Yeah it was the spri- oh fuck off maaaan. God damnit you suuuhuuuck!
You sUUUUHUHUHUck
It's like this game was designed, like this level was designed to make me angry >:|
Just inth- raaaandom chaaaance
why don'tchu- WHY DON'T YOU JUST PLAY- hadgje- EVERYONE LOVES LOVES RAAANDOM CHAAANCE
-EVERYONE LOVES GOING INTO THEIR BRAND NEW LEVEL WITH NOT KNOW WHAT THE HELL THEY'RE DOING
NOT LETTING SKILL BE ANY PART OF IT n- I don't have a lot of skill, I'll- I'll be the first one to admit that
I don't have tons of skill, BUT THAT DON'T MATTER WHEN IT COMES IN THE FACE OF ALL THE-
FUCK!- OHHHHH YEAH FUCK YOu
BUDDYEEY
FUCK OF WITH YOUR FAAAAAT face.
*reluctant sigh*
No, the spring was NOT what you needed.
It was the Yosh- 'cause you kick off o' the Yosh n' you do the-
*audible breathing in*
*very audible breathing out, sounds like a grunt*
Ohhh, weep wooo... ya stupid dinosaur
*the sigh of a man tired of life*
Okay, here we go.
How's that not making it?
How's-
Oh...
I could've made that at any point.
Wait, could I make that without losing Yosh' ?
Nah.
Well-
Alright well, there we go then I- I- I- I made it?
I- duh- ohhh noo.
Noo!
Alright, this one!
You son of a bitch!
OHH YOU ASS-BAG!
*singing* I LOVE RANDOM CHANCE IT'S FULL OF DICKS AND THEY'RE INSIDE OF MEEEEEE!
*singing* BUT NOT IN A GOOD WAYYYYYY ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
I couldn't possibly have failed any harder, at every encounter, than I have in this certain endeavour that I've done here.
And I guess this one's the winner, yes? Ok- oh oh god no...
Oh god no, the P-block? I'm going to guess and be wrong.
OH COME ON!
You are joking- oh!
*Markiplier's Amazed Face©*
Oh!
NOT ANOTHER OOOONE! NOT ANOTHER ONE, COME ON!
You have got to be joking...
*Markiplier's Sad Face©*
*sniff*
Well, a Yoshi's as good as a spring, I guess...
Probably needed the POW block
They don't even give you the common courtesy of a way to kill yourself
You have to start over.
My god...
*cries*
I don't wanna...
I don't wanna do this!
Why do I get to the douchiest levels?
Do they follow me? Do they find me?
This isn't fun, THIS IS NOT FUN
IT'S NOT FUUUU-
*sad voice* You guys better appreciate what I've done...
*sad mumbling*
The sacrifices I've made...
*laughs at own sadness*
NO, NOT THAT VENT, DON'T DO THAT!
*sad, demotivated voice* Okay...
Let's go with the Yosh.
*pleasure % = 10*
*pleasure % = 30*
*pleasure % = 60*
*pleasure % = 80*
*pleasure % = 85*
Please...
End it!
Is this the end????
There's nothing below me.
Well, first I need to check if there is anything below me, and I guarantee there's not-
Nope.
So, there must be a way to- there must be something that I can do with the Yoshi on the way back.
Maybe there's something-
Whoa, hello.
(unintelligible)
I could have just gotten the Yoshi.
Wow, hello.
Wowowowowowowow, wow, wow
What the hell?
What is, what is this?
Ohhh!
Ahhhh, I was supposed to get a spring, there.
Yeah, okay. I got it, I get it, I get it. I need to put a spring there.
Ah, okay, alright, I got it, okay, I need to put a spring there.
And that's gonna let me go up higher there.
So I need the Yoshi to be able to grab the spring-
This still isn't fun!
a- e- g- don't mistake my smiling for fun, it just means that I solved the douchiness that was presented in front of me.
Okay, so now we're gonna go back in the return pipe, we're gonna go over here,
we're gonna do this, we're gonna go back in,
we're gonna grab the spring, we're gonna go up,
we're gonna go down, we're gonna have lots of fun...
[realizes] Wait, that was a lie...
We're not gonna have lots of fun!
Okay, so...
How do I--
Wait.
Oh no...
Oh, wait!
I can just do this!
Yeah, that'll do
Then...
That wasn't the solution.
That wasn't the answer,
and now I have no goddamn idea what it wants me to do.
There's no way to get o-
Whoa, what the fuuuck? He hit a P block, apparently.
I'll take it!
This is what I have to do.
Nope!
I knew, I KNEW,
*I* Knew, I *knew* the second that I warped into this goddamned level that it was gonna be nothing but di-
Who made this?
KEVIN?!
FUCK YOU KEVIN! FUCK YOU!
FUUUUUUCK YOUUUUUUU!
FUCK YOU, GET ONE OF THESE BIG OL' NUMBERS FOR YOU
FUUUUCK YOUUUUUUUUU!
Okay, let me just- as a last ditch, I'm gonna find out what's in that question block.
[silently] And I'm going to
move on
with my life.
[gentle sigh]
[silently crying]
[cue the sad violin and loud crying]
[Grayscaling to let you, the viewer, know this is a sad moment and you should be sorry for Mark because he's sad]
Ohhh, fuuuck thiiiis shiiiiit.
[defeated] uuugh...
Thank you everybody so much for watching.
I'm broken.
Forever and always,
irrecoverable.
So thanks again
And as always I will see you...
In the next video.
*short sigh*
Bye bye...
[Outro music: Crazy La Paint by MiniMusicMan]